yeah before we get to the episode just
one of the child know I'll be on the
road come check us out
April 19th in Atlanta and April 22nd in
Orlando Florida and we're gonna figure
out some other dates in between then get
your tickets at Hannibal Burress dot-com
yeah this was a fun episode we streamed
it live on the internet with Chicago's
own Joey purp so check it out and here's
a message from our sponsors
Squarespace spits [ __ ] you know this
space sweat sweat space which is where
sweat space each person sweat sweat
space
[Music]
squarespace.com promo code Hannibal 10%
off your first purchase believe it
believe that believe it sees that we
square space square space square space
square space square space
[Music]
[ __ ] cut of the day I can't start we
can't start now using words right away
welcome to another episode the handsome
RAM of the podcast we're streaming live
on Instagram periscope and Facebook got
my co-host here Tony trim and special
guest
Joey part oh yeah yeah yes me I'm in the
building in Auto - and not auto - Joey
part with a jar of we yeah hello this
podcast is yes that was yeah I didn't
have any block bang you didn't have a
ziploc bag so I had to take the whole
jar the whole jar that's outstanding you
know that's not yeah how long does it
take you to get through that well how
much is that I just cut back I'm not
sure how much it's like a bounce house I
think it's actually I can Allisyn seven
grams I got Alison according you know
exactly how much is in there I knew how
much you started at no yeah I slowed
down
I don't smoke as much weed anymore so
it'd take me longer than they used to
the Galt House at my peak though ice
probably smoke a house every two days
hounds every two days and this one I was
like 19
what where'd you get that money from it
19 man yeah so we have that's the
auto-tune Mike but it doesn't work for
the for the internet before the post in
the post production I'm excited man
welcome so the show this is our first
time doing all the internet streaming
live think so to people that are holding
the devices are gonna get to see the
main [ __ ] that said about me whoa people
be saying some wild [ __ ] you just got to
take it you know it's all good
well welcome man Joey purp thanks for
having me how'd you how'd you end up
Joey purp where does where did the Joey
part come from Joey Joey part actually
everybody kind of made that one up yeah
yeah the part my mom named me pert No
yeah yeah my name is Joey usually and I
guess purple is just like my favorite
color
yeah yeah it was just like a bunch of
the stereotypical purp references yeah
and then I kind of just ran with it you
know it's like a lot did you ever go
with purple at first and it was a Joey
purple and then you said nah man too
many syllables it was Joe it was it was
Joseph purple Joseph purple at first at
some point maybe when I was like 17 or
some [ __ ] and then it became Joey purple
which I might revert back to but then it
became Joey part because it was concise
yeah I mean it was just like and you
realize purple is impossible to rhyme
with right that's not that impossible to
rhyme with purple circle just Norco
snorkel is it purple
slurp hurt you purple hurt you circle
work through Burke - don't stop Merc you
Merc you yeah yeah
purple search search search search you
if you wearing purple two cops to search
you don't make me hurt you again don't
stop keep going pain that I work through
Hey Oh got DVDs of Steve Urkel's Oh Oh
one of the underrated comedic actors of
all time
people don't I'm good I smoke weed this
podcast will take a weird time that's
what the theremins for yeah I can't see
here's a thing I can smoke weed but that
has to be all that I'm doing I can't
smoke we didn't have an activity that's
what I'm trying to get to I'm trying to
turn into that dude I can't do this this
show would take a turn yeah it will take
a crazy way do you like far out bro or
you like paranoid like what do you mean
at our house leave like and this is my
place
I get all weird Joey you know that Joey
Joe is what uh Chicago slang for man oh
yeah that's what my parents was thinking
that was like it's naked no be normal as
hell yeah
I wonder how that started I mean one
time I was like the water fountain when
I was a little kid and as a girls like a
gel you took her forever and I was like
you don't even know me like that yeah I
was funny
her name was precious yeah precious yeah
said our precious that's a you know it's
a real Chicago 96 96 that has never had
somebody I was a high snow grade school
her day was aquanetta
oh that's why somebody indigo Tim's that
wasn't even some hoodie that was a some
other [ __ ] yeah I remember this one is
burnt in my brain I never met this
person but I remember seeing an article
and at some times of the Tribune years
back and the child was named forever and
a day that way that's the first name I
don't want to say the last name because
of privacy reasons although once you say
forever what high school did you go to I
weren't your own I went to Whitney Young
for the first like two and a half years
of high school yeah and there yeah and
then they kicked me out and I went to
[ __ ] Truman alternative school and I
got my genes alternative school yeah I
was in that [ __ ] Whitney R is a really
good school so I feel like you know
doing anything short of like getting
really good grades and [ __ ] you're like
the worst kid ever yeah and I was just
like ditching class and smoking weed and
fighting the [ __ ] typical high school
kid [ __ ] yeah but you know that school
is really prestigious so I understand it
was like a different vibe they weren't
really [ __ ] with me yeah I went to
Whitney Young for 7 and 8th grade oh so
you smart as hell I was in a key I was
big for 7 and Ava ground what's the
Whitney Young where'd you end up in the
high school Steinmetz
oh yeah that's a big difference it's a
huge difference I guess was Buster you
is out there with the guava some of me
what does that mean
oh wow what's the Guadalupe lion some
Kalahari one waddle hour yeah okay yeah
it was Mexicans there my mask was
blessed enough Steinmetz was busted what
other schools was up there Prosser
Prosser sure what sirs sirs what Matt
there's a little further further though
I used to go to uh was that it was like
a day where every ethnicity like had
like a dance routine and [ __ ] that
matter it was called like I forget what
it was called man
it was righto they did some ill [ __ ] so
math was a very diverse school my mom
had a friend that worked there and [ __ ]
and they had this day where they would
come to the auditorium and it might have
been more than one day to be honest and
they had clubs for every ethnicity and
everybody would come out and do like a
dance routine or some type of
presentation that was like of their
native ethnicity yeah it was super it
was called shout out matter they
progressive with the [ __ ] so the black
kids just I can't remember we did I
think yeah I think my focus was foot
working this was like when I was a real
little kid though so I think my focus
was foot working at one point I can't
remember what we was doing I just
remember there was like I remember
everybody else's [ __ ] to be honest you
know how to footwork
I can't footwork now like that why not I
never really took the time to learn how
to I remember it was plenty I remember
when we were kids though and people was
like making the decision to get better
at footwork in the [ __ ] and I just cuz
you don't just start out know how to
footwork like if you're not like a foot
working out [ __ ] you didn't come up
with like with Humvees that footwork or
forward crew or whatever I don't know
like people be battling you get good at
that [ __ ] you got you know like yeah
it's like anything else takes practice
but I remember I got homies like
footwork and they like took time and
learn how to footwork your [ __ ] yeah
that's one of my biggest regrets
you ain't nota for today I wish I could
forward I didn't put the energy into it
I've never full word about a breakdance
you yeah I used to yeah I used to get
busy on not like breakdancing but like
dancing and [ __ ] you know I used to
dance I could kind of break dance a
little bit but I know more you feel me
but yeah I was more like that's hyper -
I couldn't footwork though could you do
any like power moves windmills no I
couldn't do no Power Move
no flares and I like that y'all I just
had the cool she I never took the time
to get it yeah I guess ya know I went
through the same thing like once I hit
the ground was like I can't do this you
probably was spending her yo Eddie [ __ ]
I just know I was spinning on my back
that's the furthest I got I had a cousin
in Jamaica
and he was talking he was like really
fascinated with hip-hop culture and
American culture and [ __ ] and he was
telling me he wants to learn how to
breakdance and I was like weird I kinda
breakdance a little bit and this [ __ ]
just popped and did a flare bro he was
like yeah I'll be watching videos like
yeah you would you wanted to do that
just need to be big that's your move I'm
good at what's the stuff you do before
you break down the top right yeah up
right that's where you yeah yeah that's
the groove I do that Island but no
breakdance you know I remember in high
school there would be break dancers that
were gymnast so they naturally could you
know that worked the horse or whatever
but everyone thought they were wack cuz
their feet would be too pointy and the
forum was too perfect you know I'm
talking about oh people who have purists
like that yeah man cuz like absolutely
it ruins your style though cuz if you're
a gymnast and you already got you
already know how to do Flair's your core
is on these guys would come in and be
like yeah I can breakdance and they hit
the floor and start doing crazy [ __ ]
yeah it's corny I want to learn how to
footwork when I think it's too late at
34 you don't want to tear your Achilles
forward [ __ ] that yeah Mike is one of
our words yeah
terrible how did you tell you Achilles
will you music at all well I was really
really busy to do a flare 35 I don't
think anybody ever toilet working like
you were working it really hard but like
DeRose towards Chicago [ __ ] be 10 a
maybe a fat foot working dude you know
he tried to do a spin and the stuff
don't move it you got the wrong shoes on
I don't know you know just you know I
think more in worst case scenario type
situations and my optimism has waned a
little bit anyways Tony uh wanted to
confront you about one of your rap lines
yeah yeah we would listen to some songs
in the car oh god buddy you say your
you're smoking till your eyes get asian
[Laughter]
so so so you know like smoking weed like
you'd be smoking it's just so you know
asian you feel me it might mean that
they like four or here I'm saying or you
know I'm saying I might get I might get
here with the math I'm terrible at maths
when I can't relate to that explanation
sorry how do you feel when you hear
rappers you always said yeah I'm smoking
to my eyes low like I'm it happens a lot
rap I'm smoking though now I'm Chinese
I'll be okay with it as long as you
start saying stuff like a few oh I get
surprised like
dude if you do you promise to do that I
take no offense
hi I'm on that that way I'm doing
everything like somebody particular how
long did it take to make eye drops it
took me like my whole life really on
some deep [ __ ] but on some other [ __ ] it
was like a year you think yeah it had a
we were listening to it earlier it has a
kind of New York field almost yeah I got
old school
1997 Golden Arrow type of yeah yeah good
I was I was on that I guess I was really
trying to get wraps up and make some
[ __ ] that sounded classic like whatever
classic sounds like I feel like I was
trying to make some classic rap [ __ ]
like I wanted to make a rap project yeah
I mean yeah and I guess that's where I
kind of came from I felt like it was
more like you know 2005 like dips said
jay-z era was just like the code [ __ ]
that were able to last out of the 90s
where I was like that the area we were
going for but yeah yeah yeah that way I
like I like that it's very earnest and
honest it's like is you know times and I
like that about it because you're not
trying to be you don't sound ever like
you're trying to be cool on the album
you just yeah that's cool
and I never heard nobody say it that's
cool that's like a impression you get
that's tight it's nice thank you I
appreciate it
I enjoyed we got it we got a lot of
positive reception for that [ __ ] and I'm
wearing now cuz [ __ ] might hate my
next [ __ ] cuz my next row just know yeah
put it on like this straight blonde bro
yeah yeah now I'm [ __ ] around now I'm
still gonna be rapping a [ __ ] but I
don't know it's just like I'm not going
that classic way it sounds a little more
current current like wait a bit better
there better
that way yeah man isn't how y'all make
songs y'all we're going to the studio G
and I never told nobody there's nobody
ever tone about issues of information
with this how every rapper does he
really goes in the studio right walk in
the studio producers already there yeah
engineers already there he was there
first he feels like it he's giving you
cold winter actions he's guys late so we
go engineer put the beat on he like an
engineer I'm not the producer were
producer push the bead are you going to
booth bro rap whatever isn't your heart
you feel me and then you you know I'm
saying you put it out let the people
decide oh just one take take one take
that way yeah that's what's up ass just
thank you for that insight into the
process so I always thought it was
something totally different some people
got the one takes thank you got the game
twisted yeah like going studio kind of
like throw ideas around then like you
know like hammer them out you like yeah
you kind of might say some [ __ ] that's
it or you might say some terrible [ __ ]
after that yeah but then you kind of
want to take that idea and area and
cultivate it into like a bigger - sure I
mean at least that's how I see it do you
you have friends in the studio you like
to work alone you bring bring people to
survive yeah both you catch the vibe
sometimes and something might come out
but rarely do i oh no it's both
sometimes you buy yourself and it's like
everybody's out the way and you're there
everybody that's there is there for
working purposes and you're trying to
make music but sometimes you're just in
the studio [ __ ] around and some raw
[ __ ] happens because there's like a vibe
yeah that's how I make all my hits -
yeah I just kind of freestyle throw some
sports it oh yeah I'm like you know I
hit them with the left
I'm getting all types of fans I don't
deserve like James Hart hey you be
playing - Katie
yeah plates ookay okay okay yeah I'm
decent I'm not you know I uh I just got
back into to care that's why I asked
wait you gotta tell him about the cat
the Kevin Durant story with the 2k this
is a beautiful story tell him the story
no I last Joanne all-star weekend in New
Orleans I had a I'm on a new 2k I'm on
it into my player mode okay excuse me
for not knowing this already this is a
very critical you obviously go to the
barber shop to get your hair cut no oh
okay
still critical critical shop not to me I
want to CAFO like how they had [ __ ]
ludicrous or with everyone okay that is
Oh see I thought you man you was on 2k
like that you still yeah but uh so I was
an event hosted an event for them it was
it was fun it was wedding had the best
players in the world a five-on-five they
played against each other it was very
intense these cats I forget what the
prize money was where their professional
2k players dare they yeah like they like
the best in the world video game yeah
yeah and so they played against each
other and then the winners of that game
got to play against five NBA players so
he played against Kyrie Irving Aaron
Gordon Durant who else was there
I either Sancho I left by the time be
hurry Aaron Gordon a couple other cats
yeah that they played against I think
Paul George maybe and somebody but so
Durant they were getting dusted by these
guys because they played a game plan and
so I asked to rant I say Durant if you
guys lose will you join the team next
season
and I was a little distracted he just
said hi and I walked off the response to
it was so obvious that he heard him yeah
a just he was frightened by respect to
patrol ballsiest [ __ ] don't man you
can't save zone with somebody with that
many restrictions you film it was turn
it up if he wanted to dummy like he kind
of just looks like a bully he's seven
feet tall incredible reach advantage ten
five foot ten wood flimsy Achilles heels
I can't look you guys can look that up
to Kevin Durant oh yeah yeah that was
yeah you had a situation where you would
upset somebody on accident or purpose or
you said something on record and
somebody confronted you about it
[Music]
now I might after today though you know
somebody might go he just kind of
confronted me about my night [ __ ] i it
was funny when i talked about it but if
you said hey man this is also used to it
no hard-hitting interview you know
Swaney i slanty-eyed smoking weed
references are part of hip hop at this
point and i accept it it's just like the
mexicans always call me Chino and that
basically means [ __ ] really just mean
like it's like the Hispanic dude that
kind of look asian a crime scene oh so
it's really obvious but I'm not an
asterick dude that looks Asian I'm just
an Asian guy yes
hey Janie's cake come here [ __ ]
that's good quality very poppy no I know
if it was a white guy that's it hey
[ __ ] then that's not so endearing
yeah you know yeah when you're living in
the Mexican neighborhood what can you
say yeah
Chinese man that sounds this weird
though that's worse American man and I
don't get offended by Oriya people like
some Asians are like don't say oriental
I don't care yeah oriental is just old
school which is oh yeah you know I met
you and uh leather corduroys plain the
Vic did yeah yeah that's right
28 Phil you remember he fell on the
stage oh oh on stage yeah you might not
even a knew that for me when we opened
for yourself he fell on stage it was a
slight tough fall but I will say it is
not number one in his stage boss yeah
did you did you bleep me did you miss
any bars you missed one bar but it was
right at the hip why anything he was
about to say and they [ __ ] with me he
was yeah he was about to turn up cuz it
was a turn it was a climactic point in
the verse it was right before the hood
yeah and he was about to say and they
[ __ ] with me and when he said they
[ __ ] with me
the crowd was like they [ __ ] with me
and then he he tipped over you fell off
the stage or just to the second and I
feel I'm saying
yeah it's not like Travis Scott falling
onto a heart he fell into a hole right
that was tough people have caught that
whole Ellen on stage that were shows
this year right like did he fell in a
hole Oh other people have owned the same
no yeah no not the same oh well you guys
stay just a Performa [ __ ] like a big
performance a bunch of people have
fallen through like props set stages and
yeah yeah
this happened see how that happens yeah
I guess it's like then it's kind of
funny it's a given a curse though
because you've got to be big enough to
be performing on a stage that's
collapsible with like secret doors in
the hall in the center
yeah but fall through a hole in the
stage I made it but I'm like yes I'm in
it I just fell through a hole in a stage
bro
what's your ideal production where you
got you know unlimited budget you asked
me that
yeah on Twitter I was like answering
questions from people on Twitter or
whatever and somebody asked me like
what's your dream production and I think
it'll be like Kanye for real no ID Knox
Peter can tell just blaze south side
from 808 mafia and goddamn I think that
might be just about it somewhere around
that area I might be forgetting somebody
that's critical as [ __ ] and I just
forget ski beats yeah yeah that'll be
like my seat I mean stage production ah
for the live show hanging off rafters I
would have liked Jesus I win that's deep
I don't know if that's the only nobody
for Jesus Jesus that's deep
I wouldn't even get on that that'd be
free the devil come do [ __ ] for free but
uh I would probably put like a big-ass
screen just like one big screen that
looks dumb realistic like a HDI screen
or like an LED screen or some [ __ ] and
just have raw imagery maybe and then
maybe like you know I'm saying like be
like on a jet pack or some [ __ ] at some
point jetpack jetpack no that's fire
does the fire thing though it's
pyrotechnic oh good good this new bros
2017 bro environment is gonna hit our
limited budget bro you think somebody
doesn't have a jet pack fine you guys
need to be invisible all right just you
have a for attention hype man with the
jetpack y'all got a bag
way bro okay okay so what if you own a
jet pack and your DJ and his equipment
are all something to the bar levitating
and your DJ is flown myself that's what
I'm talking about bro this is Grace on
someone oh man I'll take it that way
yeah tickets are only $500 a pop take no
videos up no right up ya know Drake and
future was a summer 16 yeah I mean and
we're staring at glowing balls like oh
oh production what I was dope we're
amazed off of going by York on my jet
packs that's the next level bade abbu
you've been in the festival circuit this
year and a bunch of us I got a couple of
festivals yeah man they let me play a
couple first of all stages I'm super
grateful for that I would tell you
Okeechobee so far we play a CL like
before a festival season and then we're
about to play a bunch of festivals in
the summertime that's right to be tired
you had Lala now I'm playing a pitchfork
it's got a lot of definitely no chance
yeah pitchfork is fun festival is about
to be dope man that the Gangster
Disciples festival contrary to popular
belief marry to 511 at the GD festival
we do not represent that ironic I was
trying to explain this like some of the
people from before and I was trying to
like tell them how that's a really
ironic this was before I was even booked
for the festival and I was like damn
that [ __ ] is really funny and they
didn't really grasp it and I just let it
kind of cook cuz I was like it's just
like a hard thing to really explain yeah
that's funny
when was your last wax show man I wasn't
Europe I had a couple that was man it
wasn't that many people there yeah man
we play Copenhagen the day that the
[ __ ] curves won the World Series
broke ha what the [ __ ] oh yeah you have
okay
people in show business co begging I
just don't have fans there like that
yeah but no we just were salty cuz we're
sitting there watching the Cubs when the
World Series on a laptop bro yeah like
blue like blue as hell yeah whole
bloodline died without seeing like
nobody sees that sad yeah say yeah we
were blue about that [ __ ] but yeah I had
a I had it it wasn't a bad show cuz it
was cool everybody was bobbing but it
just wasn't that many people there ah
okay oh but Badshah like I to tank that
[ __ ] yeah well you made a you know maybe
like cuz your heart were somewhere else
cuz your heart was at home with the Cubs
no no no this show is goodbye
yeah just wasn't I made people there but
I'm saying like a bad show like I did
bad I think that I don't know I can't
remember I try not to remember bad [ __ ]
any remember the last show I was lit
though st. Louis which was in university
watch you see the Harvard of the Midwest
they say for real I didn't know that was
like a thing but they did I didn't know
it was a good at school they were
telling me about how good of a school
yeah they spent a lot of money people
spend a lot of money to have their kids
go to school there watch news maybe I
thought you're [ __ ] around I didn't
know it was that prestigious no it is
it's a it's a high level is probably
right around Ivy League level 60 grand a
sudden a year some crazy stupid [ __ ] 60
grand a year not that bad if you think
about like isn't Latin like 30 and I
said it's like K through high school bro
hey what venue you play it one venue it
was in the school
oh it's in the plainest I pay at the
college it was like a college show yeah
cuz we always play at the pageant in
that places yeah I have a place st.
Louis the city yeah I want to play I
want to play there yeah I do not to put
Nellie jokes when I'm in st. Louis yeah
that's great still connect that's real
man that was seen it was a big [ __ ]
deal though bro yeah it was crazy
yeah Nellie was so huge that she was
platinum
yeah we need another one of these he was
so you know so much money ching-he May
because Nellie was famous st. lunatics
bingo
never be in front of a camera that's
more understandable though they had to
do with a mask they had the song or
force once st. lunatics they can all get
on that was like a lick where they got
one group song everybody gets on Tinky
Tinky on and he went crazy for two
albums he made his st. Louis Dix didn't
make hits
they were just riding Nellie's coattails
but Jamie made hit she's not giving them
enough credit man you know probably
Nellie probably wouldn't have been
Nellie without the st. lunatics hi what
does this do I should say it's a
estimate but it just goes off for the
waves okay you so can you complete this
synthesizer with like other people no
you gotta have your two hands right here
so making music back in the day used to
because you really gotta be feeling it
if you make a hit on this you a couple
hundred bucks yeah I bought it for my
niece and nephew Christmas 2015
but then I asked my sister say are they
using this and she said no and I said
send that [ __ ] back yeah that's great
theremin this is a theramenes
mug in case Moog wants to send me some
other [ __ ] I already [ __ ] with the
voyage I mean they're the og synthesizer
supercritical just I just got hip to
most from working in studio hydrops it
uses a lot of Moses yeah
JW smokes - yeah bass lines yeah that
[ __ ] is wrong it's a historical piece
you'd be making music and [ __ ] yeah yeah
I produced I like to use a lot of I've
been through a lot of
like I bought in the Seoul a lot of
vintage ones and they go for a lot of
money
yeah but then eventually I sold all of
them and just got the Voyager and the
Voyager is like mm-hmm the best one
mm-hmm
so if you buy it it's made to order so
you got to pay money you got to pay half
up front like a drug deal
that's not no you in this drug world
right and then the other half and then
they send it to you
it's [ __ ] dope it's all encased in
wood yeah and I don't want getting all
nerdy but it's no that's it oh that's
super yeah that's crazy I'm obsessed
with like analog synthesizers darl they
use tubes and electricity instead of
like digital so explain to me how
synthesizer works though I don't really
get that I guess that's not really well
I just you know like if you use an
instrument like a piano it it hits
something there's vibrations and then
the right right
synthesizer same thing with electricity
but not digital though electricity
electrical waves so you have like
vacuums and then they they they control
the amount of electricity that goes
through it and it creates this it
creates a sound can you hook that up
today no I can't hook it up to that
right now all right
Adams like I hear this nerdy - I was
gonna try to make a backdrop for make
some weird noises under it but it kind
of the things didn't work at the same
time and I feel like I was being rude
and that wasn't the case at all yo yo
first time you did my TV so now you're
my podcast I'm just I just say that to
say that I've fallen the [ __ ] off
TV show two years ago now I'm in my
goddamn apartment with microphones three
telephones pointed at me I gotta get my
[ __ ] together bounce back 2015 was on
fire yeah man I did get a thought man
again that wasn't oh gee it's crazy you
like that song I hate that song you hate
that song that song is wrong but it's
not righto my freestyle that [ __ ] is
wrong but that's the name cool [ __ ] I
got [ __ ] that's more time blaze than
that that's just a Midwest [ __ ] to
that's like some oh yeah like it's not
we really just here for what I'm saying
you're not here for the video this was
lit though the video smooth maybe that
was cool bro we had a barbecue yeah
Sam's Memorial Day me and Tokyo both
thought that the white thing was more
Morial day but it was Labor Day so we
wore white yeah but we tweet cuz that's
Labor Day and we just didn't know yeah
but we ended up with white on accident
yeah man
which I'll shoot the video what was that
at the studio we used to record at yeah
it was like right on like Grand in
Milwaukee pretty much all right around
in that area like I really was on
Milwaukee and Union
this little track man that's like I want
this track on the show what year was
that these two years ago I was too shy
through September Joey you use a regular
mic please my favorite one yeah you say
you got more [ __ ] that's John blaze than
that [ __ ]
I mean I was like that VG's key but um
what's it called
I mean got everything all I drops is
better than that song in my thing true
you know saying that song bum I got this
song bum I ate oh that's critical why my
a yes out but people kind of slept on a
little bit it was like Adult Swim single
you from oh it was with Thelonious
Martin yeah that's just crazy
yeah like by my late boomer Oh boom oh
yeah okay you remember during New Year's
bow my a real quick boom bye-yay let's
go you never heard this this is go crazy
when this come up last year he's came
out right after I drops I slept on this
man this is my this is my put my hair
stuff I just did that's a yo-yo
[Music]
epic builder how super have you build up
I wrote this out the mouse yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- yeah it goes crazy bars up I thought I
was going crazy on news you walked up to
the studio they like wrote that under
the influence now is this plan I've
written some songs off for that I took
when I did gibberish rap I was on a
smidgen of Miley
that's right you were a smidgen and just
guess fast beer and fast beer that was
yeah that was weird like that
around that time you had a weird
preference for bass beer yeah you
talking about amount of time the Molly
stone smidgen smidgen not as full I
wasn't but justice was also when you
lick the tequila or lick the salt before
you hit the tequila yeah so funny bonus
kid came up to me at Okeechobee he was
like why revered right you having fun
that's why it's not locked oh so that's
why everybody was like that song rock
cuz everybody knows what that looks like
yeah yeah can't be I I just be saying
some outlandish [ __ ] to strangers yeah
Huggy but I do I do get that [ __ ] - that
is annoying
if a woman seemed like a nice person I
mean hey we should start a life together
you say that's so good yeah my that way
she's like you do you live here I'll
move here it'd be whatever City the next
day like what a lot then I'm not moving
to Pittsburgh say that what you got to
say about New Year's Tony oh no it was
New Year's I played that song the
getting thought people were feeling it
you were nice if I disinvite Danny and
then later on you came to the turntables
and you you bullied me while I was DJing
play this I was like nah I play dope I
do know they play no what time was it it
was damn near midnight
it was past but it was like okay so look
this one's already dancing at some point
I know it was good because you have
decided that he should play Tribe Called
Quest
at which point I'm not in my head for
five seconds then I realized this
[ __ ] New Year's place with
Chief Keef or some [ __ ] bro is we are
each room yeah turn up broke and I was
like man I could appreciate chop and
some headphones I can't appreciate child
when it's you know I'm saying
26:24 yo how it happened okay conflicted
okay Tony your side I was playing some
[ __ ] that was lit all right it wasn't
tribe it was there was some current
stuff okay
but the it started because you wanted me
to play no problems at midnight
no no this was past midnight this is a
past countdown pretty sure it was like
12 15 or so she you got to play no
prongs we said oh you were right you are
playing the process and then you ate it
and it went [ __ ] it got lit but the
only reason I didn't want to is because
it was played at least five times that
night but that's what I heard so it was
probably ten times cause no matter how
many times you played as long as Chicago
people are gonna get cold
my father stretch my hands play no
problems bro - eat Ober no it was fun
and this [ __ ] gon go crazy well my
point was cuz you got on the mic and you
got him hype let me so the story is I
was doing that and then you were like
keep doing the Chicago's [ __ ] yeah and
then I went old squad I played like do
and I was like this
they don't get this and he just walked
away they would you need to change this
and walked away it was heavy the mom
wait
the first song the refers rap song I
ever put out not first time rap song I
ever put out the first video I ever shot
was first song I made trying to sound
just like do or die yeah it was like but
then I realized like you know the reason
why I do it I didn't get on and the
reason why that's funny I was just
talking about doing John not to
sidetrack but the reason why I do it
died didn't get on how Bone Thugs did
it's because they dressed both us like
West Coast [ __ ] they look cooler
yeah I feel me like they was signed a
roofless that was not easy like there
was like some West Coast [ __ ] yeah dude
I was wearing big ass pimp suits and
[ __ ]
oh and that was how Chicago dudes they
dress like Steve Harvey and [ __ ] chopper
suits bro not probably they music was he
looking but both of those music was very
similar you feel yeah but they should
just really took off more yeah they have
a look they have a look they had they
were going crazy coach do you [ __ ] with
crucial conflict [ __ ] with crew car
heavy do I don't say coal I know do you
know do you know who found true Chicago
Jam Master Jay really yeah Wow honey
phrasing
what part of the Westside was he buying
choice I don't know
they're gonna buy some crack oh shut up
some good raps
rest in peace ah yeah yeah I guess that
was a story jam I saw Jay I thought I'd
never found 50 cent Eminem found 50 cent
50 cent how mixtapes in New York
Michelle I think Jam Master Jay might I
could be wrong I think Jay message a
sudden do it 50 say if I could be wrong
all I know is that it's weird that Jam
Master Jay found this no that's crazy of
Chicago yeah that's crazy crew Khan was
going crazy bro I seen cohort coherent
horizon because I've ever seen freestyle
he came in the studio when we were
teenagers cuz Nico Segal was working at
sound skate and he was making an album
he came in studio and freestyle
ten clean verses all he knew was the
name of the song the song was called
struggles he came in Everest like okay
the song's called struggles went in the
booth freestyle that macula verse about
his life and the struggles of it yeah
and they said it wasn't good enough and
did it nine more times and then pick the
first one but he asked ten pristine
freestyle different different and their
verses they have punchlines they build
up at certain points to have different
crazy it was crazy bro well it was crazy
he liked this and yeah that shows next
level sounds like me do you feel me go
hard go hard your favorites I saw you
tweet that we would just talk about
Easter what was Brent at Johnny p2 he's
and broke them do I die past year I
think
yeah Johnny P the rest is bro I forgot
about the cat cat the past who was sing
on a Tupac song sometimes was that
nothing mind a dog that Nate Dogg but
because I gotta go over this again yeah
we have to go Tony just found out Nate
dog was dead last year
[Music]
oh gee we Kenny laughs about growing out
of respect and that know what it was
just he was just oblivion Jesus been
living thinking Nate Dogg was still
alive it was the night tour it was
devastating news to me and everybody
starting man you thought Nick dogs still
alive [ __ ] you obviously invalid bro
right no man you got invalid the
information bro yeah
you said you tweeted out east room is
like if percocet was a place yes yeah
[Laughter]
when this button is bussing yeah and
then you might think is there I saw
somebody tweeted me back like just what
you think is dead I get lit again is so
many way back that way yeah yeah East
Room was a fun spot man I went to East
Room the a couple weeks ago when I
wasn't drinking I went there late night
and like three in the morning I did so I
felt like an alien that's how I be yeah
a lot of times I've been at Eastern like
sometimes I'd be drinking turned up at
Eastern but a lot of times I'll come
pull up and not drink and just be like
gee it's getting it's escalating quickly
now that they got that five o'clock
license just a whole nother game we go
we guys we got to stop blowing up they
spot for they get closed down so [ __ ]
like he's throw to but yes it's crazy
remember and the same New Year's
probably member when Oreo got up Oreo
hopped up there it was like there was
like all these people fight like big
brawl broke out oh no no I wasn't here
or maybe I had just left cuz he play he
down there play finito yeah yeah he just
started yeah
to two songs tops yeah and it may be
that he played like Dario said that
Louis [ __ ] he plays no it was a
Louisiana and then I remember just like
they break it up and those guys sure
like and Oreos are Larry's it's like hey
man y'all calm down hey man put your
shirt back on hey man right come on
let's get together put your shirt back
Oh like he was just like he's definitely
he's definitely down to break a fight up
because if somebody's earned he was like
stop bumping around with he went into
like dad mode bum bum bum you gotta make
the delirious that sounds dope actually
whoa there were music aha
[Music]
turning my Paula theremin turns over pop
all the theremin
[Music]
yeah that's Bonnaroo this is like a
Bonnaroo late set out this is when the
drugs are dying down with the care beats
a favor you go away look right right a
bay Joey yeah we should make a live
squarespace song for our sponsor
Squarespace
Squarespace if I do the album's I get
attentive yeah oh yeah that's fair split
it up everybody's oh you know some
next-level [ __ ] rock Christmas
Squarespace make your next move go to
squarespace.com use promo code Hannibal
for 10% off Squarespace serve is that
Facebook Instagram periscope go to
squarespace.com trauma co Hannibal
get to our website step your web
presence up
all right how's this great space knock
was a lot that was intense
so good that's fun
well the last time you got in the fight
I think I was at North Coast fest yeah
two years ago I got in a fight like oh
no no three three years ago yeah three
or four years ago something like that
I'm gonna find a minute oh no you know
what it was it was yeah you can't never
mind I got in a fight like two years ago
or something like that so yeah two years
ago so last time I got a strike if the
person up like uh-huh no I went even on
that one of my friends I'm I try jump
one of my friends so who's fighting
hella people oh that was the last time I
got in a fight good good that lifting
you ever see somebody do that in a fight
lift someone up and just crush them
hell yeah somebody's broken scary [ __ ] I
see somebody put somebody on a ship I
mean that's like the best world some
nice outside or that's the best way to
make feel make someone feel very
inferior you just pick them up yeah
because it's just like yeah especially
when you get yeah yeah cuz if you gettin
pick it up like that that's what you do
your nephew if he's acting out of hand
you just pick them up and you ever flex
the family member uh no no I haven't you
flex one of your family memories
no no I'm probably out of all the family
members around my age I'm probably the
worst fighter and at least athletic so I
started just keep it peaceful and use my
words as weapons
yeah I can't be fighting man I can just
talk that [ __ ] my [ __ ] man is my
words as weapons any spare the right
[ __ ] makes you trying to bite to things
I try to talk as much [ __ ] as I can
until somebody wants to punch me in the
phrasing in
[Laughter]
don't happen I can't
Naaman I've been telling my homies that
all the time now be like bro I ain't
finna be fighting no reason like you get
in a fight bro if you if you win it I'm
not finna jump in that [ __ ] but why
shoot in a fight we finna do if you
start losing I'm trying to break that
[ __ ] up
yeah I'm saying I'm not gonna let you
get beat up why you fight that snake and
get it up that's not your fault
that's not really my fault either though
you feel me yeah but I'm definitely not
jumping nobody jumping in a fight that's
just good bro right you got to let the
guys settle it on their own and you
gotta let muhfucka start to not fight to
settle [ __ ] yeah yeah what the [ __ ] is
our fight over the people yep people
bark louder when they when they think
the boys got their back
that's facts yeah so if you don't have
the back they'll be a little quieter
that's facts yeah when when do joyed
save money how does that work UK what
you help come up with the name I know I
think I hope coming with name that was
recent vid
my homie Reese yeah Miami dick and vic
mensa and reasoning that people know
Reese yeah but uh what's the car yeah
they came up with the name okay okay
yeah we was all in high school together
we was all kind of we always there at
the same time pretty much
and so they we had lunch and they said
Joey Joey purple we have a crew no no we
was already worried I don't know how
crews get more members with meetings we
was already kind of like a thing we
wanna be a friend group get some shirts
to make this official yeah or some
Captain Planet [ __ ] yeah we wanted to
get rings but we was just in high school
yes might have initiation rituals now we
just as friends man yeah that was in
high school
yeah that was in high school at high
school okay it was so everybody you were
wrapped but you started rapping in high
school when you were a baby I was yeah I
started rapping when I was a baby for me
yeah yeah about high school I had quit
rapping I was late I was high because I
was doing other stuff I just was like
yeah I'm saying you know when you get
when you over something I just have been
rapping so much as a baby mm-hmm
when I got a high-schooler I was like
you gotta keep rapping you as he was
Lucas new little babies no [ __ ]
yeah but then I got a little older I
start picking it up again I'm saying
counting up the death of me yeah picked
it up and they say he's back you make me
tall is he no I'm trying to get into
that you see I was being real
inquisitive for a reason I'm trying to
get into that yeah that's the next day
I'm sure that's not the next thing I'm
trying to talk I'm trying to a couple
things have you already tinkered with
beats a little bit [ __ ] around I've
really tinkered with production as a
group like where like my homie Knox who
produce a lot of [ __ ] on eyedrops of
being a studio we'll be in the studio a
bunch of other people Carter plays bass
and [ __ ] and we made like like to say
you do remix we do a pitchfork we made
that [ __ ] together like I had the melody
and I had an idea of what I wanted but
they have the technical ability and the
actual honing of the idea I mean so
that's not good I mean you could
technically produce like Puff Daddy
producers yeah I want to learn them yeah
I want to learn the hardware too though
yeah I want to just know I really want
to know the terminology more so than
anything so I could communicate better
no I got you
like quantizing and [ __ ] and the amount
of DB [ __ ] need to be changed how must
have compression saying yeah yo I made a
beat what's up yeah send me that [ __ ]
pay me call it's not all his his his
snippet
was this the one you made our machine
just sound like some FK Twitter so yeah
that's my beat yo that's our hobby
that's not over is it where's the rest
of it you need to finish it this rock
can I get this yeah man I'm dead-ass I'm
a some stuff today
get some auto-tune on there no no no I
need some other stuff can I get that I'm
dead serious
I'm like Louis was teaching me how to do
some Ableton yeah what you came up with
that's what you know I have some other
ones - that's just let me finish that in
the stuff you got the drums I got I'm
gonna sit with some other people are
kind of try to develop another idea of
it okay and then it'll be able to have a
Hannibal Burres production put dog [ __ ]
hurts on the beat see man this is this
is how you do it Network this is how you
network you put your dreams out there
yeah and he says you know what that [ __ ]
isn't that ready yet we got to do
something to it but isn't there I said
it's fire waiting to happen bro yeah man
yeah there's like some tribally drums
but everything I was making sounded like
that you know that one web video what
else God knows you know that what they
doing that dance the goth kids yeah what
it was like hey I'm trying to learn how
to do that hey there's a raver dance
yeah Rayford is when they got the air
movement and they kind of they was doing
actually the lobby yeah yeah and they
cut it goth kids yeah they just put
their way to the middle of it whatever
like is a big turn up song and it goes
with anything
yeah movement but everything I was
making in a studio that day was sound
like something yeah god it would be very
sped up yes I'm going there it was like
primal and travel
yeah yeah I got to get a studio man make
some beats some chance some sense that
she would gotta go cause you can go hard
with that yeah yeah both theremin yeah
Joey what's your biggest regrets in life
oh no man biggest regrets hmm I kind of
regret not like dedicating more time to
like school like your actual school
while I was there because that's just
cool you know I'm saying you learned a
lot and then I also regret like getting
kicked off the football team for me
why'd you get kicked off the football
team no I'll keep it going keep it going
keep it going keep it going
that's the vibe yeah I'm saying like I
got injured and then [ __ ] the
assistant the assistant coach of the
frost soft team was lowkey super petty
he ended up getting fired for some other
[ __ ] he was making like prejudiced jokes
at kids and [ __ ] oh man you can't do
that yeah so he was just a [ __ ] in
general but he kicked me off him because
I won't come to practice because I was
injured granted he caught me at a
volleyball game chillin I was chilling
watching the girls volleyball game with
a couple of my friends you weren't
supposed to be there now I was supposed
to be at practice technically I was hurt
I also wasn't on the frost off roster I
was really on the varsity roster I just
wasn't playing I was on the varsity
roster don't defend me I just was hurt
so I'm like all right I'm not gonna come
I'm not gonna come to practice I'm also
not on the frost off team I'm not trying
to play it frost off games I'm trying to
get on a varsity roster so I'm really
not even for them listen to you cuz you
didn't get me in school I didn't get
into Whitney on you feel me mmm I got in
for I didn't get in through testing or
whatever I got in for football so I'm
like I know the varsity coach I'm on his
roster
and then he kicked me off the team and
didn't consult nobody and I found out
the next year of school that the varsity
coach didn't even know I got kicked off
he thought I quit I was like I'm this
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] that got fired kicked me
off the team and then nobody even know
about it y'all thought I quit football
I'm like well I can't play football but
yeah biggest regret bro since that [ __ ]
yeah I'm sad I would have been more
disciplined right you my name be here
right now if you kept playing football
so I'm saying bro might be how are you
three you'd be 23 you might be I
wouldn't be in the league but I might
have just had like an eel job because I
got a scholarship to college or some
sheep right
oh maybe Canadian Football League now I
win the photo like that no no sorry you
wouldn't go to Canada what's wrong with
Canada I'm [ __ ] with Canada I'm trying
to go to Canada football in Canada
however it's probably not where I would
have spent my life right no dude Oh
class a different kind of football right
you know more people get shot in like
the first month of the year here than in
a whole like five year span in Canada
Canada yeah overall campus as a whole
though yeah the whole country bro I'm
Chicago yeah they just got no poll out
of spirits that is spirits no pose no
poles no guns
Oh nobody has guns or maybe they do have
nothing they just not shoot each other
with it I think it's less guns and it's
just tougher to get guns and they got
good health care so that is nicer and
the summer and even if they are shooting
it is yeah they got health care and they
don't want to shoot each other close
like the natives were shooting each
other no he ain't got no insurance they
will put so much pressure on the
healthcare system with all the gunshots
so they just collectively as a country
decided not to do that and there's a lot
of different things we can learn from
them and the summers are mild heat makes
people [ __ ] crazy people crazy in
here when we don't have any heat yeah
it's cold as [ __ ] all year and as soon
as it gets hot we get to tweak it but I
don't think he makes everybody crazy
people go to well I guess people do that
a LAN go crazy oh you onto something bro
crazy Africa who's your dream features
dream Wayne yeah Wayne
Kayne will be crazy jay-z would be crazy
Dryden crazy obvious people cars but
Wayne for real quiet little Wayne Wayne
or three stacks yeah cuz Wayne is like
how do you I'm 35
so George a is he's he like your
favorite rapper ever who jay-z no who's
your favorite rapper ever
you can't ask me that question
all right yes I got so many who's your
favorite rapper Anibal I'll get back my
pointers to that let's talk about his
airway my plane is like the jay-z NAS
biggie like certain people you would be
like why is he the best and like I
understand what all these people are the
best but like Lane is like that for us
like Wayne was better than everyone for
such a long period of time that he's
like the pinnacle of rap for me guys a
Wayne definitely but then all those
other people to jay-z would be right
next to that okay that's not I don't
think I know people my age that that
well I think for the most part is
probably your age thing though cuz I
only I'd respect jay-z so much for what
he's done for this part of his career in
my lifetime but I have all this like my
oldest brother is like 42
yeah so I I was listening jay-z to him
being a jay-z fan because that was his
[ __ ] he was growing up at the same time
so I appreciated the ojz first so I
understand why he's why he's so
influential yeah cuz he like dressed
like him you know what I mean like
people was wearing the clothes he wore
yeah I remember when jay-z said I don't
wear jerseys I was 30 plus but no I was
great [ __ ] was wearing button-ups in
my grammar school then I started wearing
button ups to button up dress shirt
striped joints it was whatever sucked in
and then they had the rock yeah great I
had the rocket wear polo with the
Panther I had the same like fade as the
color of the pole oh yeah oh killed him
on the first week of school but then it
was weird cuz I saw him at Barclays what
he did all those concerts for the
opening and he had on a Jersey and he
did that lice and I don't wear Jersey
some thirty-plus this is this is not
working maybe he was just trying to be
ironic
maybe yeah he's a funny person he's a
funny guy yeah so then Wayne feat so you
thought you just it you you you thought
of a song or you need song in your
catalog we say Oh Wayne would have been
perfect for this that's out already
yeah oh he would have snapped on God
buddy I got something aren't out yet
that Wayne would be perfect for it but
he would have snapped on God body I feel
like he would have went crazy on girls
that in like 2008 or some [ __ ] yeah yeah
I'm saying when he was killing all the
features
got body but not but not 2016 Wayne
could do body right now honestly but it
would just have it would be like more of
a vibe
then cuz he was like yeah Jeff Wayne
from that era in that setting you know
what I mean
best your favorite little waiting song
it's too many but I would probably say
somebody asked me there's no Twitter to
probably say blowing up fast is one of
them this song called everything off
like 500 degrees or summers really oh
and then the song called [ __ ] the
world off that same album those two
songs he probably made when he was like
a teenager them shits are so wrong bro
one of them's about his dad and then the
other one is just about the struggles of
his life at that age and you realized
what type of a setting he was in and the
kid like he already had a kid as a kid
you know I'm saying yeah I started like
15 or some [ __ ] he was grabbed by his
daughter at 16 17 years old it was just
all types of [ __ ] he had enough bread to
have problems about money like what
you're a teenager bro and still rapping
about his mom cuz he's a kid it was so
raw that's why I like Wayne to be I
found him as a kid yeah he was young
rapping about certain [ __ ] I can
identify already as a child like a young
dude cuz he was so young but he was also
balling outrageous that it was like he
was like he was on The Hardball single
in a movie hardball yeah everybody was
rapping about baseball he was rapping
about pitching drugs I never thought he
was a kid but he was a situation yeah so
that's yeah that shit's robbed oh yeah
but that's not fast or everything in
[ __ ] the world yeah yeah yeah just one
of my old weight favors this one right
here
this it was wrong it's like this is like
he'd do like spoken-word on him yeah
this is crazy like yeah he was burning
incense indecision no he wasn't it was
not burning his bed he was definitely
drinking heavily but is this super
spoken word and yeah I don't think he's
ever made it blowing that fast it's kind
of like that it's not as spaced out but
it's like that same vibe though
everything he's saying is like yeah
blowing that fast is kind of like that
too he just says a bunch of stuff that's
like it's not like a bunch of rap lines
there's just like things yeah like he
said I wanted points tastes like
robitussin there's just a bar it was
just like I woke up in the morning
something he said something about his
breakfast and then he was like my own
place tastes like rubber tastes like
it's early in the morning just woke up a
drink some orange juice I drink some
water punch it had lean in it Joey
[ __ ] you [ __ ] with like the like the
little yachties and the little Aziz you
like you know yeah return ya to it like
at parties and [ __ ] yadi can actually
rap though people don't give him credit
for rap yes have you heard issue with
low Earth no no she has with low herb is
a raw as hell what's it called next
three played that [ __ ] he gets bars off
on that yeah oh god he can't rap bro he
just I feel like maybe the other
shooters just easier for him or it's
what he likes to do it yeah but it's
funny I don't think Lucy Burke can rap
like y'all do rap because I never heard
him actually rap it was like a [ __ ]
wrapped
vlaka was making oh that's the Ottoman
[ __ ] you want to turn up [ __ ] and it was
raw but then he dropped the song when he
was wrapping it and it was like you
forget an item from New York and [ __ ]
like yeah you said it's called up next
three you know it was uh you saw the
video of yachty at South by Southwest
where somebody in the crowd said I guess
the crowd was kind of dead and then he
yeah he was talking about it and a guy
was the guy watching in a Chrysler
you ain't got no energy my [ __ ] and a
yachty gets mad and then people from his
entourage bottles of water on the guy it
was was the crowd turned that no it was
a little you know I got weird because
yeah it got really weird I wish I we
played we played a show in Minnesota and
we played that song and it was lit yeah
yeah okay here we go
[Music]
[Music]
no this is actually goes crazy garage I
didn't even know he could I don't even
know he can talk that fast
yeah that's it was wrong he took some
adderall oh that would have been crazy
shout out so it's a little yeah rap
really fast nah not really fast can I
think you can I know I never really do
actually because I can't is hard to do
live yeah I'd like to do [ __ ] that I oh
yeah yeah that makes sense you got it
when you record you got to think about
the performance otherwise you just gotta
like get the hype man to do it sometimes
we end them smoothly and into mono but I
just feel like did it any any pardon
words mr. Leaphart can I can I be on can
I be on the rest of you on the rest of
him mmm no excessive be but I want in
the future but not the rest of them is
this you got to make the people miss you
you know what I mean is that you
trying to make the people love me be
yeah so it's internship run it better
you get some auto-tune liveliness for
the people make the beat for me can we
exit with like a look better better no
that's not a good
[Music]
we out this [ __ ] that way
all right check out eyedrops available
everywhere out hey I'm dropping a
project called quarter thing quarter
thing queer thing
all right look out for that quarter
thing yeah eyedrops I check out eyedrops
no my favorite yes that way
peejoe
[Music]